en 2022 les chefs de partis sont partout
sur les médias sociaux certains
choisissent l'humour oui
d'autres expliquent leur engagement
associé notre plan pour lutter contre
les changements climatiques
mais est ce que ça fonctionne vraiment
peut-être que c'est une des manières de
les accrocher les jeunes adultes mais il
faut faire beaucoup plus que ça c'est
pas juste de faire des très courte vidéo
drôle pour accrocher les jeunes c'est
aussi parler de ces idées qui
d'expérience les jeunes adultes sont
prêts à écouter du contenu plus long où
on parle d'idées où on parle vraiment de
propositions des propositions sur
l'environnement particulièrement on
aimerait voir l'environnement comme une
priorité absolue on aimerait voir des
mesures dans les programmes qui sont est
aussi drastiques que les mesures qui ont
été prises pendant la pandémie un futur
angoissant qui affecte la santé mentale
des jeunes un enjeu qui revient aussi
pour sacha winky dont l'anxiété est
accentuée par le coût de la vie il ya
plusieurs jeunes justement qui se
demandent ce qu'ils vont avoir la chance
de leur parent de leurs grands parents
il déplore que les chefs ne propose rien
pour le portefeuille des jeunes ce
serait bien d'avoir une annonce pour des
allocations dédiés aux jeunes justement
qui sont victimes directes des victimes
du raid 10 juillet de l'inflation les
québécois entre 18 et 34 ans sont
presque aussi nombreux que les 65 ans et
plus mais en 2018 seulement un jeune sur
deux avait voté élections québec veut
renverser la tendance à la demande allez
voter pour ce faire les jeunes doivent
prendre conscience de leur pouvoir
politique
c'est tellement une partie importante du
vote qui était tout simplement pour
représenter donc aller voter le 3
octobre c'est le plus important
voilà l'appel est lancé ici marie josée
paquet comme radio canada montréal
oui
[Musique]